family is super important to me Rob
Kardashian is taking matters into his
own hands when it comes to his family
smile et has learned Rob recently filed
documents seeking primary custody of his
three-year-old daughter dream whom he
shares with ex blac Chyna
Robert Kardashian you are the father the
couple went their separate ways in 2017
after a very public and very dramatic
breakup and have been co-parenting dream
ever since this new legal filing would
reduce China's parenting time to only
weekends with a nanny present Rob is
asking that the supervising nanny have
the authority to end the visit
immediately should they witness any
violence around dream
TMZ who was first to post the news also
reports that Rob alleges in the docs
that his ex drinks heavily uses drugs
and gets physical reportedly the 32 year
old reality star also claims he and his
family particularly sister Chloe have
noticed a recent negative change in
dreams behavior and personal hygiene Rob
is honestly the best dad he reminds me
so much of my dad and how attentive and
fun and loving he is with her the docks
also include a request for China to
submit to drug and alcohol testing no
less than 30 minutes before each visit
with their daughter we're all in a good
place
China has yet to address the matter but
this is quite the change from just
months ago when the former couple
announced they had reached a
co-parenting agreement that worked for
them at the time at China told et this I
just feel like having like a good
relationship with
the parent and co-parents it is like a
healthy type of thing in this something
that a lot of people needs to like
practice et has reached out to both
Kardashian and China's reps for comment